um
[Music]
you've got two devices sitting side by
side you get a receiver and get a
transmitter yeah
because you've got a receiver
is
[Music]
here
boys
is
for a long time
um
um
seriously
no
it's like a little squad
yes
um
the same
i know
even if
die
this
um
uh
and
jason questions uh
thanks sir
where you want me buddy
it's been a long time yeah you're good
yeah how about you
excellent thank you
i don't know what do you guys do do they
mask
won't tell you
not too sharp all right
how are you
sounds good just do me a favor get right
to that first uh baseball card right
away okay
i'll be down
wave to me alice
you
so
so
harris good afternoon i'm wearing a mask
as are all the journalists assembled
here
in the breaking press briefing room
we're awaiting uh kayleigh mccanney as
soon as she comes out of course i'll
step aside
i want to tell the folks at home a
little bit more about that document
which as you know was declassified
by the director of national intelligence
john ratcliffe
he actually uh transmitted that over to
capitol hill and that document showed
that then-candidate trump
was free and in fact his very first
intel briefing
back in august 2016 it was led by fbi
agents who
had just opened an investigation into
his team's ties to russia
that document a seven-page summary of
the meeting
it was actually pinned by as you pointed
out
signed off by kevin klinesmith and peter
strzok
the former fbi agent and one of the key
figures in the ongoing russia probe
at the time the president said last
night in his conversation with sean
hannity that
a lot of things have been learned about
the probe and what happened leading up
to the election
and after his victory and what happened
then
is a disgrace and should never ever
happen
again so the president is obviously very
passionate about this
i think the real question for a number
of folks not just here at the white
house but all over the country
is what will happen to the people that
participated
in this activity was it in fact unlawful
or was it just
unethical we've talked a great deal
about the durham report and possible
indictments
nothing's happened yet much of the
consternation of the man whose office is
not terribly far
from where i'm standing right now a
couple of things i think you should keep
an eye on today uh harrison i want to
talk to you
about the stimulus a lot of americans
are depending on that money
they need it will they get another check
will be 1200 bucks maybe 600 bucks
we'll have to see how that all plays
itself out and what about drug pricing i
know you and i have talked a bit about
the importance of lowering the cost of
prescription drugs
that's something that we'll also learn a
bit more about today for now
back to you as i'm trying to keep my
mask on my face
yeah that's interesting uh you know what
we typically do when you cover this beat
is you make lots of phone calls exchange
emails have conversations at 6 30 in the
morning sometimes
and while the president is clearly
frustrated that i guess
the way it was put to me was head bloody
but unbowed they're going to keep
pushing forward with this idea
of coming up with a stimulus package and
also coming up at some point
for the payroll tax cut listen if you
ever look at your check
and you see what goes out of it in terms
of payroll taxes
the idea of not having that money go out
for a while would probably make a number
of americans very happy
that's something they still like to have
but sometimes you pick your battles
timing is everything and they understand
right now
it's about getting something over the
finish line to help the millions of
americans desperately in need of money
harris
thank you sorry about the mask
thank you
is
okay
listen up thanks pal
we'll catch up
um
i'm not sure
please
my mother
thank you
hmm
oh
first
all right
step three
okay
um
actually some houses
crazy now
no no
okay
foreign
yeah it's crazy
right
okay
simple
yeah let's go let's go
um
um
so
oh
not yet
uh
wait no he said
is
uh
what that was great
perhaps
two minute warning
biggest
this is
uh
you
so
you
hello everyone the first duty of
government is to protect the safety of
our citizens that's what attorney
general barr
said when he was here at the white house
just a few days ago
for 55 days in portland oregon we've
seen lawlessness
anarchy and destruction that threatens
peace in our streets and the safety of
our fellow american citizens
and the safety of our brave law
enforcement officers
yet some democrats and some in the media
continue to ignore
reality as portland's portland's
democrat mayor ted wheeler tweeted quote
what i saw last night was powerful in
many ways i listened
heard and stood with the protesters and
i saw what it means when the federal
government unleashes paramilitary forces
against its own people that was a quote
from the democrat mayor who quite
literally stood in the middle of a riot
as violent protesters attacked a federal
building
that is appalling and mayor wheeler is
clearly
failing at his duty to protect his
streets and his city there in portland
the federal government has a sworn duty
to uphold the laws of the united
states through field offices and federal
facilities across the country these
agents protect
and serve the american people yet the
rhetoric of the left undermines our
justice system with nancy pelosi calling
them storm troopers
jim clyburn calling them the gestapo and
wheeler using the term
paramilitary forces under president
trump violent crime rates in america
finally began to fall rhetoric like this
cannot be allowed to set us back
augmenting the federal protective
service guarding federal property in
portland
our brave officers have since augmenting
them i should say our brave officers
have faced
all of these various things like rioters
barricading officers inside the hatfield
federal courthouse
trapping officers inside a commercial
grade mortar firework was launched by
rioters
a federal agent's hand was impaled by
planted nails
another federal agent was shot with a
pellet gun leaving a wound
deep to the bone and tragically three
federal
officers were likely left permanently
blinded
by the rioters using lasers pointed
directly
at their eyes these are not the actions
of so-called peaceful protesters and the
trump administration will not stand by
and allow anarchy in our streets law and
order will prevail and i have a short
video for you
because i wanted to be real uh what is
happening right now in portland so if we
could play that video that'd be great
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see that is anything but a
peaceful protest and this president will
always stand on the side of law and
order and with that i'll take questions
yes thank you so much first of all has
president trump determined where he's
going to or how he's going to deliver
his speech he said he was working on
that yesterday
so he hasn't decided that just yet but
we have a number of really creative
exciting options that he's looking at
it's a question
more for the rnc but he's on very
excited about the prospect of what will
come with the convention
about something that he tweeted back in
april he said joe biden wanted
the date for the democratic national
convention moved to a later time period
now he wants a virtual convention one
where he doesn't have to show up
gee i wonder why does the president
regret that now
well as you know i can't respond to joe
biden you'd have to ask the campaign
about that
um but the president the circumstances
changed in florida where we intended to
have the convention as the circumstances
on the ground changed
the president changed his viewpoint on
having the convention in jacksonville at
that particular location
president's phone call with vladimir
putin did the president raise the issue
of russian bounties on the lives of
american troops during that phone call
so as you know that intelligence is
unverified still to this day there are
dissenting opinions within the intel
community i won't get into the
president's private discussions with a
foreign leader
i was not on that call but that
intelligence is still unverified but
rest assured our president will always
stand
with our military and protect them
against any and every foreign
yes um adversary pelosi and mitch
mcconnell announced that john lewis
will be lying in state at the capitol
monday and tuesday
does the president plan to go to the
capitol to visit john lewis
on one of those days i have no
announcements about the president's
upcoming plans but john lewis was a
civil rights icon
we lowered the flag at the white house
here um to to signify that so i had no
future announcements of the president's
plans other than to make that one note
yes thank you so the senate has approved
uh
overwhelmingly a bill that would
require the renaming of faces that are
named after
confederate leaders how and
how is it that senator involved assured
the president
he was going to be able to remove that
from legislation that has
passed both chambers of commerce yeah
i'll leave that to senator inhofe as to
how that works legislatively speaking
but the president
was assured by senator enhoff that that
would be changing
and that republicans stood with the
president on this and stood with the
rest of america 56 percent
according to an abc ipsis poll or
opposed to the changing of the us
basement
okay kaylee thanks uh two quick
questions um
i think you probably hear this often
when
can americans expect some money in their
pockets by way of stimulus what's the
president's
plan to get that money to them as
quickly as possible
and just a question about comet
reporting is the white house at all
concerned about
inaccuracies or inconsistencies with
respect to cova death report
so um first let me note um when it looks
at when we look at numbers we want the
most
accurate reporting um and i went through
last week at the cdc numbers we want to
make sure hospitals are truly
reporting um all the information they're
getting one of the systems of data
gathering
only 81 percent of hospitals were
reporting into another hhs system
was getting a more full picture of what
we're seeing in hospitals so we want to
ensure all of our information is
accurate
i mean we trust the numbers that we're
getting from hhs and cdc
i mean with regard to those negotiations
are ongoing
these are long and extended negotiations
we feel that it's very important from
the white house to address
unemployment insurance in particular um
and also money for schools and
ensuring that the money for schools
enables students to make school
choices like actually going to a
physically open school so
right now that's where the discussions
lie at the moment one more quick one
very quickly uh drug pricing
is so critical to america's seniors uh
often you hear terrible stories frankly
about people having to
ration drugs because of the incredible
cost what exactly practically can
the american public expect the president
to do to lower the cost of
prescription drugs that's a great
question i'm the president today at 3 pm
we'll be talking about drug pricing
and he'll be announcing some actions
he's taking on that front so i'll leave
it to him to announce
those future actions but you know in
2018 he released a landmark
blueprint to lower a prescription drug
prices it's an issue he's been very
passionate about which is why he signed
legislation ending the gag clauses that
stop
pharmacists from informing patients
about lower drug prices and
average average basic premiums for
medicare part d
prescription drug plans have actually
fallen by 13.5 percent
since 2017. so he's done a lot already
but more to come
this afternoon actually caitlyn i have
two questions for you this morning dr
burke said that it is still an open
question how rapidly children under 10
can actually spread coven 19.
but the other day the president said
they don't bring it home very easily and
they don't
transmit very easily so shouldn't we
figure out which one of those it is
before kids
go back to school so let me give you two
um answers to this you know first i
would point you to cdc guidelines um
that said based on current data
um the rate of infection among younger
school children and from
students to teachers has been low
especially if proper precautions are
followed
there have also been few reports of
children being the primary source of
covenant
transmission among family members that's
where the data currently stands
but that being said even if there is
transmission and later studies come out
let's say we believe that students
should be going back to school because
the effect
on a child we know scientifically they
are not affected in the same way as an
adult
um again i'd point you to cdc guidelines
on this that says the best
available evidence indicates that
children become infected they are far
less likely to suffer
severe symptoms death rates among
school-age children are much lower than
among
adults and far lower than during the
h1n1 pandemic for instance when schools
remained
open yeah and dr brooks knows that today
unless kids have an underlying condition
but she said they do not know how
rapidly they can
spread it still for if they're under 10
and that's one of the president's health
advisors so on the transmission point i
point you again to the cdc but i would
also say that it is our firm belief
that the that our schools are essential
places
of business if you will that our
teachers are essential personnel you
all here are considered essential
workers which is why you were coming
into the briefing room every day during
the pandemic our meat packers
were meat packing because they were
essential workers our doctors were out
there treating because they're essential
workers and we believe our teachers are
essential
particularly i pour over the um the data
on
on schools often and the one thing that
really stuck out to me i read through
the entirety of the cdc guidelines was
that
i talk about child abuse often and one
in five cases being reported in schools
well the cdc guidelines went on to say
there has not just been a sharp decline
in reports of suspect
suspected male treatment but tragically
a notable increase in
evidence of child abuse when children
are seen for services during the
pandemic for example
in washington dc child and family
service services agency
recorded a 62 decrease in child abuse
reporting calls between mid-march and
april
compared to the same time period in 2019
but saw more severe presentation of
child abuse cases in emergency rooms
that's a tragedy and our schools must
reopen
okay my question was about transition
rates but anyway my second question is
also
in the president's call with the russian
president yesterday
today the nation's top
counterintelligence official said that
russia is one of three
countries that is actively working to
interfere in our election did the
president bring up election interference
on the call with the russian
president yesterday again i wasn't on
the call but the president
i was not on the call the president for
the president has taken more actions for
election security than his predecessor
who
gave a stand down order when he learned
about election interference susan rice
gave that stand down order
um obama's intel chief even confirmed
that stand down order was given by
contrast we've
uh given enumer a ton of funding to
election security
we take our election seriously and we
believe in election integrity
justin i was not on the call caitlyn
stop filibustering justin let your
colleagues ask questions
justin okay justin no longer has a
question anyone else kaylee uh
okay around 20 million americans
are receiving expanded on insurance
benefits and some are going to
receive the last of those checks
tomorrow um have
senate republicans in the white house
settled on a plan yet to
extend ui if so can you explain what
that plan
is and if not did you wait too long to
try to sort this out those discussions
are still ongoing and i'm not going to
get in the middle of the negotiation
other than to say
when i answered kevin's question up here
i said that our priority
right now is we feel it's very important
to address extending on those
unemployment insurances um and how that
looks i'll leave it to them but that is
unemployment insurance is a top priority
for us right now china ordered the
closing of one of our diplomatic
facilities
there in retaliation for what happened
in texas um
we haven't really heard from the white
house if you can spell out specifically
why you guys decided to close the
houston facility i know that there's
obviously broad
complaints that you've raised for weeks
with china but
why houston specifically and secondly if
you had a reaction to the steps china
took
yes our action to direct the closure of
the prc consulate general in houston was
taken to protect american and
to protect american intellectual
property and americans private
information
for years the ccp has undertaken a whole
of society effort to steal american
technology
and intellectual property for commercial
gain and many of those activities are
directed
from prc diplomatic facilities and we
urge the ccp
to see these malign actions rather than
engage in tit-for-tat retaliation so
that's where we stand on that
okay the president's tone on the virus
this week
seems to have changed he's uh advocated
a few different times for americans to
wear masks
he said that the virus would where the
pandemic would get worse before it gets
better
he canceled most of the convention or
certainly the florida part yesterday
all of these things were bad two months
ago
even longer than that and the science
unmasking has been clear for
uh several months what changed this week
why did his tone change
there has been no change the president
said on march 31st before there was even
a recommended but not required
um guidance given by the cdc on mask
wearing
the president already said if you want
to wear a mask wear a mask it doesn't
harm anyone and that was before that was
one of our scientists even more some of
them were saying don't wear masks so the
president
has been consistent on this he wore a
mask back at the ford facility
he carries around in his pocket he
showed it to you multiple times
he hasn't changed um in fact and just
speaking on kova generally
um the way i've heard him talk privately
in the oval office is the way he's
talking
or the only thing that changed is the
dozens and dozens of your questions each
and every day because he felt the best
way to get information to the american
people was for him to be out here
on answering your questions and
providing this direct the other part of
the question that wasn't just about
masking although i would argue that if
you look back and see when
he called it politically correct for
example that that wasn't exactly
agreeing with the science of wearing
masks but
setting that aside no but let's not set
that aside because in that incident when
he used the words politically correct it
was in reference i believe you were
asking him a question was it
and right and you were standing outside
and you'd been tested and you were
wearing a mask and he couldn't hear your
question so he asked for you momentarily
to
pull down the mask so that was the
specific context and context does matter
here
okay well i didn't need to engage on
that but i was standing around other
reporters and using the same mic that
other people were using that's why i
left my mask on
right well he could not hear your
question he asked for you temporarily to
pull it down everyone in the press pulls
tested so
scientifically you are not in a
compromising position but he's
he hasn't changed his tone um but this
president
the reason he wants to bring back these
briefings is to get information out
there like we've done 52.9 million tests
nationwide 187 emergency use
authorizations
use use authorizations excuse me for
test manufacturing
20 million swabs per month use the dpa
over
all of these great successes of this
administration like distributing 31 000
cases
of rem de severe enough to treat nearly
200 000 patients none of this is getting
covered
and you've got the best messenger the
dually elected president of the united
states
talking directly to the american people
and getting extraordinary ratings as
they tune in to get information from
their questions
what question wasn't about john that
last piece i just want to clarify one
thing caleb okay john no longer anyone
get five questions people in the back
row don't even get the opportunity to
ask questions
i want to ask about the senate defense
authorization bill which passed by a
veto proof majority yesterday and the
house earlier this week also passed
their
version of the defense bill also by veto
proof majority
and both of those bills contain mandates
that the pentagon
renamed these military bases which are
named in honor of confederate generals
i want to ask you does the president
believe that his position which we're
all familiar with
it's helpful in terms of recruitment it
specifically for african americans
explain how that position
will help recruit african americans in
an all-volunteer military force
the president stands with the american
people 56 don't want to see the bases
names change where he stands is in a
place where
many soldiers who have lost their lives
overseas the last ground that they saw
were these bases
and by changing their names he believes
um that
that it is not appropriate that those
soldiers who lost their lives
to be told that the grounds familiar
with this position i
and you just restated it very well but
i'm asking you specifically
how is this helpful for an african
american which who wants to volunteer
for our all volunteer military forces
to go to a base that's named for a
confederate general
that worked to still put
and keep in place slavery which impacted
their ancestors because the bases are
not known for
the generals they're named after the
bases are known for the heroes within it
uh the great americans black white
hispanic of every race who have died on
behalf of this great country
and 56 of the nation agrees with the
president's position it will
impact it won't impact then it won't
impact in any way
recruitment is what your position is
next question
kelly i want to circle back to school
choice which you mentioned
a few minutes ago um so that that means
shifting the potential for shifting
federal funds away from schools
that don't open so that parents can use
it use those funds for homeschooling or
private schooling
the president vehemently opposes
defunding police
why why is defunding public schools okay
so the president has never wanted to
take money away from schools take money
away from education it is about keeping
it with the child the purpose of school
funding
is to educate a child the child if a
school is close
loses the opportunity to receive
education and needed social services
i put up the chart a few weeks ago from
mckenzie and co that showed that the
student
most impacted is the low-income student
who's in a low-income community and
doesn't have the resources
as some other students so that student
should not be deprived of an educational
opportunity and forever never be able to
recover
um the deficit um that that child has
had by being out of school for an entire
year or more
schools in those in those underserved
communities
also are the ones that generally have
terrible ventilation
they need the most money for upgrading
if this money is shifted away from those
schools
how will they ever get into a situation
where they
could in the case of a pandemic properly
serve their population well your
questions a bit befuddling because if
the problem is ventilation in schools
and the school's closed and you're
fixing the ventilation
the student isn't even in the facility
because the school isn't even open the
whole point is the student deserves an
educational opportunity and a good
educational opportunity
which is why the money must follow the
student and i would also note
in the cdc guidelines that they said um
with regards to food in particular that
there are 15 million children
participating in the school breakfast
program 30 million in the school lunch
program and they said quote
it is difficult to maintain this type of
school nutrition program over the long
term
and they were talking about how we've
managed to get meal service
meal services throughout the periods of
school closures
uh but they went on to say it's
difficult to maintain this type of
program
severe consequences i've mentioned the
child abuse the loss in education
and also when it comes to nutrition
services as well yes
um the payroll tax cut uh now off the
table is there anything that the white
house considers a red line and
uh negotiations for democrats and then
also another question
yeah there i'm not going to get into red
lines these um negotiations are ongoing
and i'm not in the middle of them so
i'll wait to
find out what the conclusions of those
negotiations are but i would just signal
what i said at the top of this briefing
about unemployment insurance being very
important
and then uh trump called off the
convention in florida citing
safety um does that give him pause for
any of his future upcoming travel like
to
texas next week which is a hot spot we
take all necessary precautions
and we protect the president his staff
and we make sure that we're following
the guidelines and social distancing
and so we don't have concern about
future travel yes
the accusation that china is feeling
intellectual property are not you
but why can't this order shut down the
consulate in houston
no yeah i'm not going to told you that
i'm not going to give any further
information
about our intelligence from the briefing
podium
earlier on that particular
thank you kelly uh reopening schools
yesterday uh
cypress president announced that he was
going to so the
republican convention events in
jacksonville he also made the case again
for real in school so
is it not safe to hold a republican
convention but it is safe to reopen
schools
schools are a different situation when
you have children who
as the cdc guidelines clearly note um
are not affected in the same way as
adults
we can make certain arrangements like
social distancing in schools and follow
the cdc guidelines that have been laid
out and try to they're the best world
guidelines i referenced
we can get our schools up to the the
best place we can get them in especially
if we're given additional school funding
the 105 billion that was mentioned that
we would are keen to see
um in a phase four so it's a different
scenario when
you have packed adults in the room
versus these students that we can um
make precautions and take measures to
protect yes thank you kaylee
i have a question about coverage but
first i want to ask about these federal
officers
does the president believe he has the
power to send dhs
agents and officers anywhere in the
country that he wants to uh the
president
believes that his authority is in with
regard to
um dhs which is distinct from doj
there's operation legend
uh which is primarily led by doj and
that's just providing extra fbi and atf
and dea agents to already existing uh
places it's just surging
extra personnel in places that are out
of control like chicago for instance
um separate indistinct from portland
which is dhs and his power
pertains to 40 u.s code 13 i i read that
statute for you in the last briefing so
i won't bore you with reading it again
but that's with protecting federal
property so those are the two
lanes that we've um acted on and look at
for those dhs
those officers and agents does he
believe he has the power to send them
anywhere he wants
he believes they're there to protect
federal property so i'll leave it to you
to determine where's federal property
just just to follow up on that i mean
has the president reminded those federal
relations and officers that their
constitutional obligation
to not violate certain seizure rights
take people into custody without
probable cause well chad wolfe is
leading this operation
and he has made clear that uh his
officers are acting in the bounds of the
law of course we encourage everyone to
act within the balance of the law in the
constitution
he said he loves the constitution we
haven't heard him speak about that
particular part because
his context president trump has
repeatedly said that he wouldn't watch
sports or support sports if players
continue to kneel
um so why has he agreed to throw out the
first pitch at the yankees game next
month
if the considering that baseball player
is not that lost tonight's games
yeah i'll leave it to him uh as to
address um the yankees game he's very
excited to throw out the first pitch and
i was not a part of the discussions as
to how that's going to work in terms of
the first pitch i've learned about it
when you guys did and he's very excited
to throw it out
yes thank you kaylee two questions we
understand that the governor of florida
is on campus today can you confirm that
can you talk about that visit will he be
meeting with the president
yes governor desantis is here um he's
here to be a part of the drug pricing
event
um but he will be talking and meeting
with the president further to discuss
covet and other matters
will they be discussing the convention i
had two questions if you
i may ask the second one this is why i
like to save time for you guys in the
back i appreciate it
yes uh do you have any guidance on when
the president will be signing that
immigration order that he's been talking
about
yeah so um no guidance um other than to
say i laid out that
he would have a mayor-based eo and he
really would like a legislative fix for
daca and would like democrats to come to
the table but no guidance on timing just
yet
chanel thank you kaylee on federal law
enforcement efforts
namely operation legend we're talking
about funding for a lot of these
programs anytime we're talking about
federal
anything we should be talking about the
money behind it um
so with operation legend it appears to
be filling
a law and order void in majority
democrat cities
so given this fact in terms of the
funding
would the citizen of say springfield
missouri be called to
pay for the security and the federal
protections of
the incompetence of chicago illinois is
that something that has been discussed
as far as funding for
operation legend um i'm not aware of
that being discussed in particular i
think where the president's head is at
right now is you know you look across
the country and it is
democrat streets where you're seeing a
lot of this lawlessness um and
minneapolis murders have spiked 94
philadelphia murders have spiked 27
percent over a year ago
new york city 277 percent increase
in shootings over a year ago chicago the
most egregious 414 people killed 50
increase over a year ago we saw with
under president
obama violent crime started to tick up
started to come down under this
president he restored law and order
um and then this defund the police
movement has been an absolute travesty
and it's why
um you have 67 of black americans who
worry that
the criticism of police will cause
police to pull back
so this president is looking at this in
a saving lives lens i want to save lives
i'll put federal money in um
as he did um financial assistance was
announced with a.g barr
and also additional manpower he's very
keen
on seeing the violence in our streets
and he wants to protect the people of
this country when
derelict democrat mayors and governors
do not um and he's also
appalled by cancel culture and cancel
culture specifically as it pertains to
cops we saw a few weeks ago that paw
patrol
a cartoon show about cops was canceled
the show cops was cancelled live pd was
canceled
lego halted the sales of their lego city
police station
it's really unfortunate because i stand
with and the president stands with the
63 percent of americans who think
police officers are one of the most
important jobs in this country that's 63
percent
um and with that i caroline lovett one
of our great assistant
press secretaries um today went to great
pains to make contact with the south
hold police department in suffolk county
uh we saw a very touching video that we
loved uh and she got the approval of the
police department and the parent to show
this video because i think this is
emblematic of where
america stands with regard to our police
if you wouldn't mind playing that video
that'd be great
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you when you grow up
thank you to our heroic police
department around the country america
stands with you
i think
thank you
okay
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
one two
you